[Musique]
je
le shérif
ce cas d'abandon mal
on était tous les indices et les regards
plus nouveau show géniaux les valeurs
s'en prend au 032 faut pas que j'oublie
ils m'ont enlevé deux cabarets commencé
à courir sur le haricot vert comment ça
va les inviter
il ya pourquoi là bas pour regarder les
numéros c'est un super et aussi avec mon
vieux complice ina j'ai toujours avec
moi il est là toujours fringant un bien
entendu bon fabien lecoeuvre
comment il va j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
bercé les chiens c'est le cas de la
barbarie des numéros incroyable
aujourd'hui on l'a et isabelle
morini-bosc comment ça va jaser mais je
suis rami j'ai hâte de voir ce qui va
venir c'est joli ça va tout alors
toujours avec talent il compte toujours
son cactus fais gaffe à pas de pitié je
suis pas mal mais pas encore à ça c'est
géraldine maillet la romancière
commentaires très content d'être là ça
alors c'est quoi le dernier bouquin j'ai
écrit un bouquin pour enfants out c'est
à dire là dessus ah ouais tu sors rien à
sa droite apparaît que t'as pas une
anecdote là sur anny duperey par exemple
et l'asie non annie duperey non non je
voulais te parler de daniel balavoine
bref zioui ça t'intéresse haut parleurs
asie que tu veux dire balavoine
balavoine c'est un mec formidable
ouais j'ai eu l'occasion de prendre le
train avec le libre-échange à la [ __ ]
le chabab a barré
le cabaret dans c'est quoi ces 5
millions exceptionnelle pour avoir ce
soir et tout d'abord on va démarrer avec
un tour de magie alors les chéris vous
allez voir c'est un gars il s'appelle
maximus les neet us et il vient avec son
assistante
agathe petites routes vous allez voir
c'est un couple de moldaves sont de
véritables magiciens ils savent faire le
show pour un tonnerre d'applaudissements
ici et là bas et c'est parti
ma cousine cus et agathe reebok
allez c'est parti mendy mon petit doigt
me dit que je vous le suivi dont tu fait
partie
partis à vélo m'a dit que maintenant
c'est l'instant mais j'ai joué avec à
mes côtés ma partenaire à agatha et pour
la première fois elle va me mener à la à
la vague est très bien nous allons
débuter le tour par un classique de la
magie le tour des fameux globulaires
regarder une balle de petit bal 30 et
dwan est également un petit gobelet 2 et
3 la première balle d'attention je la
place ici d'accord 1 2 vous tapez dessus
passage
deux fois plus de magie
deux fois plus de suspense de vous taper
et la magie va aller là-bas alors c'est
la plus compliquée parce que c'est là
d'ailleurs je prends un peu de poudre de
perlimpinpin voulez vous soufflez je
veux bien soufflé disparition et bien
sachez
elle mettra au monde leurs gammes et
pour cela vous allez mettez rieuse mes
côtés rien dans les mains rien dans les
marais regardant le clip et jugera tous
dans la citrouille très bien voir
derrière eux les mains sur elle est bien
ici ici se passe quelque chose de 3 de
plat par un foulard à l'intérieur mais
les flux tendu ça c'est fabuleux
on le met la une deux trois hélas la
disparition va opérer l compliqué vous
soufflez vous tapez j'espère y aller ce
qu'il ya deux tours de mon situation de
rats manche je chercherai la même
tangente ont cure et n'a droit garder
[Applaudissements]
gardot nagata extraordinaire proches os
et d'avril aussi hilare avons préparé
son numéro je peux vous dire c'est
génial ce qu'il a fait et on reste
conscient net et puisqu'on parle et de
ballades ouais y'a adolescents habitant
en angleterre il ya eu un magicien
saluer fasciné voix c'est un type qui
ont levé la culotte défi à distance non
bien sûr mais bien ses moules dans un
chapeau lui seul c'est génial c'est une
géniale c'est génial on va passer un
autre numéro les chablis un petit coup
là et c'est parti pour une petite coupe
et c'est papin ont apprises et bien
entendu r non merci j'ai arrêté n
oubliez pas bien sûr de voter chez vous
parce que vous allez voter pour le
meilleur numéro et on va prendre
quelqu'un au téléphone qui gagnera un
magnifique cadeau si elle a le bon
gagnon qui a gagné sur twitter où les
combats prennent tout de suite au
téléphone on y va on l'approuvé pas tout
de suite sans la [ __ ] on va accueillir
le numéro suivant on va prendre juste
après il s'agit d'un chilien oui c'est
juan miguel amiguet
j'ai fait de l'exil beauce corps
d'assaut tous c'est à dire qu'il exhibe
son corps avec une corde à sauter vous
allez voir il saute à la corde et qu'un
pantalon beaucoup trop grand pour lui tu
pas si vous rappelle quelques soul
vous allez voir il va laisser comme on
lit des traces dans l'émission c'est
parti c'est grand cabaret c'est génial
[Applaudissements]
on rappelle tout le record est de dix 10
autres cordes à sauter on va voir s'ils
arrivent à faire plus c'est parti on y
varois 2003 et recon santiago macias
[Applaudissements]
non mais qu'il est con
il est professionnel on est forfait
social mais reconnaissent attends
attends attends attends attends attends
que tu tiens mon vieux tu pètes de
profil par contre attention j'ai
l'impression est apparemment tu as perdu
une canette de coca cola donc en train
de bannu l'a bien compris d'où je vais
te dire mon dieu tu dois faire des sauts
à la corde
si on part et des caisses la gorge sur
une perte comme mènera attention et ça
ça c'est un numéro de la relève au chili
j'étais sur le cul regardez chez vous
c'est le grand gabarit on y vend numéros
comiques hausse c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
les seules hausses efforts brouillé par
tia kia numéro fourie ça vous a plu aux
tongs la table tant qu'art dos à toute
annonce exactement avait raconté serge
gainsbourg ah ouais ben azzouz ya il
avait et quand il était enfant et un
gardien qui s'appelait joseph pujol a
sauté tout le temps pour ses abdos
pourquoi parce que son métier il était
il était pétomane et un pétomane d'avoir
les abdos a jamais eu et ça c'était un
numéro de cirque incroyable début du 20e
siècle est très important il savait
marquer bien ce bourg non souverains -
est à papeete par contre peuvent voir
les noix prendre la personne de
téléphone qui secoue les cherry et dans
un instant on va accueillir une virtuose
du piano est une russe elle s'appelle
valérie nabil ayouch cas vous allez voir
elle a des doigts de fée elle est
géniale
elle est géniale pour l'instant je crois
qu'on a sabah au téléphone s'allume
assabah salut ça va ça va ouais ça c'est
patrick patrice evra ça ça va tu aimes
bien mais les éditions je t'entends pas
à bon temps
ça va tu nous appelles ou pourquoi près
de lille j'adore aura sous les lillois
et les oiseaux il ya un club échangiste
abba génial le est le saut touche pas
ouvrir pour ce pack des moutons là bas
tu veux jouer tu va nous dire quel est
ton numéro préféré dans un instant si tu
as le même humour ont préféré tous les
twittos ce1 tué téléspectateurs tu
partir avec un magnifique cadeau qu'est
ce que c'est que le tchad au bar amène
ton cul ouais c'est une montre collecter
d'accord plus un téléphone téléphone
smartphone plus humide ça fait plaisir
ça bas à wynigen à l'évacuer le
troisième numéro c'est valérie n'a
benhaim ushl à une virtuose du piano
applaudissements pour cette russe aux
doigts de fée et je peux vous dire
qu'ils voient c'est parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion
car connaissant sa raquette dans la
nôtre et la somme ou lire apparemment et
s'est passé là petto que mal joué avec
les boules c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est beau mais droit n'ont rien fait
c'est vrai c'est le principal on
applaudit ses trousses
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est génial et j'ai vu plonger sur
nicolas [ __ ] c'est bon que ces bourgs
accès book un bon niveau vas-y ma chérie
allez vas-y ou valérie la baie animaux
jusqu'à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
six mois puis ça va durer tout benneteau
en attente du plaisir du public
ouais bah tu sais quoi tu allais voir si
je suis propre sibérie d'accord merci
applaudissements pour elle ces juniors
reichel et gdf ce qu'elle arrive à faire
c'est génial s'évalue à nabeul les
chiens on a une annulation de numéros
des garçons qui nous d'annuler qui tenir
par un numéro tu pourras pas devenir
malheureusement parce qu'il est bloqué
au cap d'agde dans un jacuzzi
on y reviendra nous voir prochainement
bien entendu et on le retrouvera bien
entendu au toucher à tout achat tout le
dernier numéro soir alors je vous dis
c'est un artiste c'est un artiste génial
[Musique]
très vite il vers des balkans il est un
des balcons je connais votre compte en
émoi les balcons cemac us de la minus a
veillé voir alors oui c'est le roi de
limitation le pays de sylvie vartan 1
raconte nos instructeurs sursis nivard
tentiez non s'il va maintenant c'est
surtout l'orientation ce qu'il faut
expliquer moi j'ai rien connu tirer le
luron web le numéro qui faisait c'était
pas forcément les imitations bref il
imitait pas avec la voix ouais mais ils
ont tous une en faisait la femme qui
pisse
ouais c'est à dire qu'il prenait du
champagne hébreu alors plus l'envoyer le
jet loin plus les jeunes peuvent plus sa
poule et londres c'est un peu la
médaille alors c'est ça et ça c'était un
cercle privé n'en consomme
non non non et ça c'est une vraie avec
d'autres frais c'est bien elle s'est
avérée c'est de la merde alors
c'est de la merde mon les bleus a quand
même c'est pas bien le tube mercy fabien
c'est ça c'est mon fils et ça c'est mon
pote ça c'est mon pote tu es de la merde
c'était bien c'est génial génial c'est
mathus double manuce alors mathus de
l'eau banus vous allez voir c'est un
imitateur exceptionnel mal quand il va
le confirmer
c'est parti on y va et la jaguar ya
c'est génial c'est le caca baba bâ
ouais aux accessoires et tout salut les
amis vainqueurs de leurs muses on avait
parlé donc humour et imitations
producteurs dans la salle
ouais je ne suis pas venu seul nom j'ai
un petit peu la portion que le johnny
hallyday aimerait vous dire un mot
mairie salut c'est joli l'autre jour
j'ai rencontré deux enfants j'ai donné
5000 euros plus grand et 2000 aux plus
petits mais savoir pourquoi parce que au
plus petit qu 2003 merci beaucoup et ses
jumeaux jeanne et pierre patry qui
arrive dans le coin c'est important
qu'il est avec nous c'est jean patrick
salut c'est patrick qui aurait alors
passé la [ __ ] je ferme les yeux je
trouve au mercy était géniale mesure la
mutation du tapa truc à nous raconter
partie chameau en fait j'ai un petit
problème à temps j'informais m en fait
j'ai un problème je suis venu mais j'ai
que montsoult des gauches
est ce que quelqu'un sait quelle horreur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que là là là là on entre on est en
train là on est en train je vous le dis
la ja c'est un artiste en train
d'assister à la révélation manar qui
seront remises aux autres allez voici le
faisant rouler encore jay carney michela
mais à petit à petit pour vous c'est
spécial c'est charles aznavour est là et
vit encore et wes coupe attention sait
pas où il veut les huit ans que j'ai
quitté nrj 12 est bien décidé à taper
baba le coeur léger et le sexe est lourd
j'étais certain qu'il est homosexuel et
c'était pour toi c'était c'était pour
baba simon gass kodila tedika les c'est
pas pire alors c'est fini et l'infini
brad pitt a été génial attention on est
avec nous et ça lui a tendu que le
montant retenu qu on voit ce que voulez
vous dire c'est qu'en fait match nul en
maths c'est vraiment le meilleur des
chroniqueurs les autres c'est des gros
cons du partage en main royo tu fous ou
quoi t'as un truc à dire ah ben il va
arriver tout à l'heure autre que de les
lire c'est pourquoi il donne pas plus de
prime time et à matthieu delormeau il
fait ce qu'il veut et jean-marc à celle
ci je sais je n'aime pas avec tous des
blaireaux j'ai voté sur twitter au delà
les résultats je suis pas les chalonnais
qui s'abat ça va pour toi qui a été le
meilleur du mur on irait mal maximale
est le numéro de magie est ce que c'est
ce qu'a gagné ce qu'on peut me donner et
bien agathe le foot
agathe le pontet maxime et bien c'est
gagner c'est maxime
c'est la vie
[Applaudissements]
ok
quant à lui
pas tant
ce sens la meilleure
tjx cos d'abord